let's just say it gets a little bit
crazier before it gets any better
kendall Jenner stopped by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show on Thursday and dished on
those reports that our big sis Kourtney
Kardashian is quitting and Keeping Up
with the Kardashians I think Kourtney
kind of has boundaries which is totally
understandable if Ellen's ever looking
for a side hustle she could totally
moonlight as a hard-hitting journalist
because she got right in there
addressing the double standard on the
show kendall has never really shared her
personal life while Kourtney is kind of
expected to I've always kind of not let
my personal life entirely on the show so
it's just kind of always been a thing
for me but then with Kourtney she did at
one point let her personal life be on
the show and so now it's a bit more of a
shift I guess for everyone to understand
but like is Kourtney quitting or what I
don't think she's fully confirmed to not
be on the show let's just say it gets a
little bit crazier before it gets any
better well I guess we have that to look
forward to but let's be real fans of the
family's hit reality show have already
watched a lot of this drama go down just
because you love to show every single
thing because she likes to show every
single thing I don't like what you do
clearly because that's our job it's not
it's not our train is your it's theirs
yeah there's a fine line oh and remember
when Kim straight-up dropped the F word
like no no not that F word this F word
we'd have a proposal for you it starts
with an F and ends with a D Savage
yeah but Kim has a point our job is
being open and honest and sharing a lot
of ourselves and it just seems like for
the past few years now Kourtney hasn't
really been open about her personal life
on camera so all of the days that
Courtney isn't filming Khloe and I are
picking up the slack and having to share
more because if we're not sharing our
lives then
what is the show when et caught up with
the famous sisters in October they
weighed in on courts future with the
show you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there but
I'm not saying goodbye do you think the
show can continue going if you lose a
sister we definitely love portney and we
will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time this family we are feel
like at the revolving door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back but back to
Kendall so there's a picture of you and
I want to I know that you're a huge fan
of cheer you were a cheerleader right
yes after I watched cheer I was like I
was definitely not
Ellen surprised the 24 year olds who was
a cheerleader in high school with the
cast of Netflix new hit show cheer
morning love Morgan I love Morgan I love
Morgan too Morgan know
and she got right in there and doing all
those sky-high moves
jump in okay and then and then they're
gonna do stand straight up but I want to
I got you yes oh and Kendall also
revealed she has a makeup collab with
her sister Kylie coming out soon I had a
contract before with another makeup
company so now I'm able to do it I feel
like we're really going big cuz I'm the
I'm her full blood you are our full
blood sister taking it seriously
very cool well it looks like we have
makeup and drama coming our way courtesy
the kardashian-jenner I mean how
on-brand is that of course you can count
on ET to help you keep up with the
Kardashians so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]